[Music]
yeah when are you moving home some lucky
[ __ ] and things I can't explain so
this movie is also about you know the
links that a father will go or his son
we know how much you love your kid you
love your kids daughter Corinne is just
coming back home 23 years old
we just did a movie together me her and
my youngest daughter I guess I directed
a film called all-star weekend and she's
in it and my youngest daughter is in it
and just to see them you know we see
your kids like your kids going oh my not
do any I tell somebody it up yeah
speaking of cuz she's so pretty
the fellows would you tear some fella
I'm a bad tune I think that has to
already be sort of known by anybody that
yo because I think that sort of lets the
guy know they like yo you better come
the right way because you don't want
that to have yeah but it does say
something about the links did you think
about that like what would I do
oh I I do anything you know I've got two
young children myself and my daughter is
she's only eight but already I'm just
sort of bracing myself for those
teenagers for those years my daughter's
very cautious and very you know my
oldest is a little bit of a late bloomer
when it came to those matters and my
youngest daughter has a thing of she's
already a romantic she's eight but she's
a you know like she had a full book get
a little bored Brittany single holding
hands nice my oh you know so it's a
little different in her sense that's the
fun part of it it's taking what you know
yeah and being the person who is a the
male perspective to tell what your
daughter this what they going to you
touch my son I'll kill you the actor
also got candid about another personal
matter
weight gain six months seven months ago
I was 216 pounds not paying attention
hey mr. Chow's and the order and mutton
and I think I had a yak my public what
would you do
yeah you better have a baby so I got
with my trainer care and we go up to the
Sports Academy to get that thing off
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
you